how's it going everybody its Lauren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and the MCU today we
have some very very interesting news
once upon a time there was a Twitter
account by the name of Roger
Wardell now this Twitter account leaked
a ton of information about Avengers
endgame and about the upcoming Marvel
phases and the account ended up being
100 percent right including things like
seeing fat Thor and Avengers in game
scene the very first TV character to go
to film and Avengers in game which of
course was Jarvis
he said Robert Redford was going to be
returning in a scene with Tony Stark
Loki and Scott Lang he said Black Knight
was being heavily discussed and Miss
Marvel was being heavily discussed as
well all of these have come to fruition
with Marvel well there's a count hasn't
posted for a while and people were
starting to wonder what exactly happened
to it but now it seems like it has come
back up in a second account instead of
Roger Wardell it is Ward L Roger and the
account seems to be talking the same
exact way as the other account did and
it's actually believed that the old
account was discovered and this is his
new account and with this new account
comes a lot of news and one specifically
I want to talk about in this video is
the fact that he says that Norman Osborn
is headed to the MCU now there's a lot
that comes with this because of the Sony
Marvel deal but I'll break it all down
in this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
Marvel related content and stick around
to the end for giveaway details so this
account was created at the exact same
time as Roger Ward ELLs old accounts
last tweet and that seems to be a little
bit more than a coincidence
in past tweets he said that Thunderbolt
Ross would be returning as well as ghost
and Justin Hammer for the Thunderbolts
and we know that they're being set up
right now currently and in a new tweet
he said general Ross believes he can
control everything from the backseat his
pride and ambitions backfire badly as a
new leader shows up both weapon Plus
program and extremis virus bring the
long-awaited
arrival of Red Hulk now we know this for
the most part to be pretty much true
there have been a lot of reports about
the Thunderbolts coming to the MCU and
about Red Hulk as well so so far this
information is accurate and giving us a
little bit more than we know but then he
tweeted again saying david morrissey and
robert Odenkirk being eyed for the role
of Norman Osborn however his Green
Goblin altered
ego will not be happening anytime soon
so Norman Osborn is headed to the MCU
but according to this tweet we won't see
him become the Green Goblin at first now
let's bring this back to before
spider-man hom happened there were some
people who went to a pre-screening of
the film who said that spider-man far
from home had a post-credits scene that
featured Norman Osborn the building that
was once the Avengers tower turned into
the Oscorp building Norman Osborn would
make an appearance although they would
not call him by name but he would be the
person in charge of assembling the
sinister six this could be the same
route that the MCU is headed right now
and this could be because of the rights
that Sony has on the spider-man
characters however we do know that Sony
and Marvel have been playing nice lately
and it appears that they have more plans
for spider-man in the MCU after his next
solo film and team-up film so perhaps
the next step of evolution for
spider-man in the MCU is introducing
Norman Osborn and since Sony and Marvel
are playing nice together they could
actually use Norman Osborn's name
however Marvel may timidly not want to
introduce him as the Green Goblin yet
and they won't need to because they
already have an established sinister six
that could enter the MCU we have
scorpion chameleon vulture Morbius venom
and Mysterio he doesn't actually need to
suit up as the Green Goblin he could
simply establish and control the
sinister six which apparently is what
this original post-credit Spiderman far
from home scene was supposed to be and
that would tie into this new report
stating that we are going to get Norman
Osborn of the MCU but we won't see him
as the Green Goblin just yet eventually
we will so we know spider-man has one
solo film coming up next year and then
we know that he has a crossover film so
perhaps the crossover film could be the
sinister six and then after that his
future in the MCU could introduce Norman
Osborn there's also the possibility of
the Dark Avengers Norman Osborn could
lead the Dark Avengers but not take on
the mantle of the Green Goblin just yet
but let me know what you think about the
possibility of Norman Osborn being
introduced into the MCU
again this is not an official
confirmation but this new account does
seem like it is from the old account as
well and that old account was 100%
accurate with all of its reports so let
me know what you think down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
turned on to stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 and picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers as always thank you
all so much for watching we'll forth